good morning John thank you for your
lovely video this week answering
questions about sex and relationships it
was so universally well-received that my
sibling rivalry has kicked in and now
I'm gonna answer questions you better
than you I'm gonna eat answers for
breakfast but I'm going to be answering
questions from Facebook and Twitter
about adulthood and growing up what's it
like to do taxes imagine if you will
you're sitting at home reading a book
there's a knock on the door you open it
up and there's a mat or the top hat and
a beard and he says we would like you to
contribute to your society by paying
your fair share for things like a
defense and education and health care
for old people and you're like yeah I
mean okay that sounds reasonable to me
who should I make the check out to and
then he starts hitting you with a stick
I don't know why it's so hard how do I
deal with Peter Pan syndrome look
growing up is what you want it to be
we're grown-ups now and it's our turn to
decide what that means being silly is
still allowed that's not excluded by
adulthood what's excluded by adulthood
is thoughtlessness so be thoughtful and
silly why are job applications so awful
I don't know but they are maybe you
should go into human resources in
revolutionize how we hire people in this
country cuz it's pathetic and bad how do
you deal with the loss of free time look
all time is free and as you've
progressed through life you have had
things to do and you will still have
things to do but there will still be
lots of time for you to do other stuff
just don't spend it all watching TV how
do you live an active social life on a
budget have parties at your house or
other people's houses fun silly parties
you can watch Harry Potter or like write
up fake wills and tell everybody who's
gonna get your stuff and never ever ever
buy alcohol at bars I can't imagine a
faster way of spending money with less
benefit how do you get past your
insecurities if you fail I will like you
more
so fail start failing now I order you as
an adult is it still okay to watch
Disney movies in crime the literature
just I'm really speed up as you get
older yes and I imagine you've already
noticed this happening and I don't know
why it happens and I'm not a big fan of
it but would you go back to being
younger if you could no no no no apps
not know I like having a much deeper and
more thoughtful understanding of the
world and I didn't back then I remember
like junior year in high school people
were like this is the best time of your
life and I was like oh it better not be
how do you establish good credit hey
your bills if you get married is it okay
to still hang out with friends of the
opposite sex yeah but if you're like
hanging out with them by yourself and
you like have this mutual urge to lick
each other's mouths
then you should stop hanging out with
that person how do you make friends as
an adult I suggest first that you keep
the friend that you've always had but
you make friends the same way as you
always have mutual acquaintances common
shared interests figuring out that they
don't annoy you as much as other people
and then make them dinner or go bowling
or do bad karaoke together that's tough
but how do you know when you're an adult
you don't I'm sorry we pretend like we
live in a world of harsh edges but there
are no harsh edges there are no borders
between these things those hard lines
are all imaginary and they're just
created for convenient or it's loving or
growing up or raising a child or having
a job these aren't destinations they're
not achievements to unlock life isn't a
video game it's a journey
everything is a journey and we get to
travel it together and I hope I hope
that you enjoy it John I'll see you on
Tuesday
you